Traduttore: Cecilia Secco
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Io sono un agricoltore.
Le mie sorelle ed io
gestiamo un'azienda agricola.
Abbiamo sempre fatto anche dell'altro,
[e] questo forse
ci conferisce un’attitudine
a cercare di rompere
gli schemi classici della produzione,
[a] provare a cambiare.
Magari l'abbiamo imparato
dai nostri genitori,
agricoltori anche loro ed eclettici.
Cerchiamo di avere il famoso
“approccio laterale” ai problemi.
Ci riusciamo? Vedremo!
La nostra bisnonna Regina -
veramente si chiamava Caterina,
ma tutti la chiamavano Regina,
coltivava la terra
nelle campagne friulane.
Piantava il grano, il mais,
fagioli fra le piante di mais,
bruciava l'ulivo per terra
per ingraziarsi la protezione
di Santa Barbara
contro fulmini e tempesta.
Possiamo sorridere oggi
di queste superstizioni,
ma devono darci l'idea
di che cosa significasse
il terrore di perdere il raccolto:
significava fame.
La nostra bisnonna Ida coltivava
la terra nelle pianure venete,
vendeva le sue primizie
davanti all'ospedale.
Dopo la fioritura del mais
tagliava la pianta sopra la spiga,
per dare quella parte di verde
da mangiare agli animali,
e la spiga maturava con quel po’
di foglie che le restavano.
Se producevano una tonnellata e mezzo
per ettaro erano contenti!
Noi oggi ne produciamo 12, 14,
ma il record è di un agricoltore
della Virginia, David Hula,
con 33,3 tonnellate per ettaro.
Mica male!
Ma il mais è una pianta
dalle potenzialità incredibili.
Vorrei condividere con voi
alcune riflessioni sull'agricoltura.
L'agricoltura è ciclo,
è ritmo delle stagioni,
è tempo, è maltempo,
è pianificazione,
è investimento, è rischio.
L'agricoltura è provenienza
ma è anche prospettiva,
è tradizione ma è anche futuro.
Allora la domanda che mi pongo oggi è:
riusciamo a innovare le nostre tradizioni?
Riusciamo a prenderle, innovarle
e consegnarle migliorate
alla generazione futura?
L'agricoltura è ciò che ci dà da mangiare,
è quello che deve sfamare
un pianeta sempre più affollato.
Gli agricoltori non si sono
mai sottratti a questa sfida,
per esempio quando hanno
sfamato un’Europa
che usciva devastata
dal secondo conflitto mondiale,
e lo hanno fatto innovando.
Ad esempio introducendo
la meccanizzazione,
passando da questo a questo.
Ma il tempo del progresso
non è lo stesso per tutti, o ovunque.
Questo è Dario, oggi, sulle Ande,
che lavora il terreno.
Quello è Giampaolo, oggi,
nella Pianura Padana,
che lavora il terreno.
Oppure abbiamo introdotto
la fertilizzazione per nutrire le piante,
o la chimica per proteggerle
dalle malattie, dalle malerbe,
e passare da questo a quello.
Quelle erano le mondine,
ore ed ore con le gambe
in ammollo nell'acqua
a mondare il riso
fra zanzare e tutto il resto.
Ma l'innovazione
di gran lunga più importante,
quella che è responsabile del 50%
dell'aumento di produzione
che si è avuto negli anni,
è il miglioramento genetico.
Quell'uomo è uno
dei più grandi genetisti italiani,
uno di quelli che la genetica agraria
l’ha veramente insegnata al mondo.
Si chiama Nazareno Strampelli
ed è anche grazie al suo lavoro
se siamo passati da coltivare
frumenti così alti a quelli bassi.
E perché vogliamo piante
di taglia ridotta?
Be', perché quelle alte
sprecavano molte risorse
a produrre stelo e foglie
e poca granella.
Per di più cadevano
facilmente, si allettavano.
E quindi la raccolta era complicata
e il prodotto, stando a terra,
si guastava, era di cattiva qualità.
Le piante ottenute da Strampelli invece,
[che sono] basse, sono più produttive,
quindi possono essere fertilizzate.
E il prodotto è di qualità migliore.
Il tempo ci ha portati
da nutrire due persone per ettaro
di terra coltivata, negli anni '50,
a quattro e mezzo oggi.
Negli anni '50 un'agricoltore
sfamava sei persone,
oggi cinquanta.
Grazie a queste innovazioni
abbiamo potuto produrre di più.
E abbiamo liberato forza lavoro
che si è spostata dall'agricoltura
all'industria e ai servizi, sviluppandoli.
E i bambini sono potuti andare a scuola,
invece che a lavorare nei campi.
Oggi all'agricoltura si chiede
di produrre di più
senza aumentare l'utilizzo di suolo,
senza aumentare
la pressione sull'ambiente,
prodotto di qualità migliore,
a costi accessibili
e soddisfando consumatori
sempre più esigenti,
cioè l'agricoltura
deve essere sostenibile.
E deve esserlo per l'ambiente, è evidente.
Deve esserlo per la società,
che deve poter conoscere e condividere
i nostri metodi produttivi.
E deve esserlo economicamente:
un agricoltore deve poter vivere
dignitosamente del proprio lavoro.
Se manca una di queste tre “gambe”,
l'intero processo produttivo
non sta in piedi,
l'agricoltura non è sostenibile.
Fatta questa premessa
vorrei cambiare discorso,
raccontarvi quali scherzi
ci gioca a volte il nostro cervello.
Albert Einstein disse che è più facile
spezzare un atomo che un pregiudizio;
il pregiudizio è un muro,
nella nostra mente.
Noi tendiamo a prendere decisioni
basandoci sulle emozioni,
più che sull'analisi intellettiva.
Il nostro cervello
si è evoluto in condizioni
in cui la priorità non era
il ragionamento fine, da curato,
ma la decisione rapida.
Questo salvava la vita, e questo
la pressione selettiva ha fatto evolvere.
Anche nella vita di branco
la priorità era far parte di una tribù,
perché questo dava protezione.
Ancora oggi il nostro cervello
cerca di proteggerci
dall'ingresso di nuove idee,
punta a preservare il nostro senso
di appartenenza, di identità.
Le nuove idee sono una sfida
che accende nel nostro cervello
la stessa area che elabora
le minacce fisiche.
Ecco perché tendiamo a reagire con forza,
a volte con aggressività, alle nuove idee.
Davanti a informazioni che mettano
in discussione le nostre convinzioni
noi tendiamo paradossalmente a reagire
rafforzandole ancora di più.
Si chiamano bias cognitivi,
sono molto forti e ci caschiamo tutti.
Combattere l'ignoranza,
nel senso di mancanza di informazione,
con l'informazione
è a volte come gettare
benzina sul fuoco.
Guardiamo cosa sta
succedendo con i vaccini!
Io rimango convinta che sia
comunque il metodo migliore,
anche perché,
se conosciamo come funzionano
queste trappole del nostro pensiero,
forse riusciamo più facilmente
a disinnescarle.
Il marketing le conosce
molto bene e le sfrutta.
Lo fa in modo del tutto legittimo,
ma noi ricordiamocelo,
soprattutto quando si tratta
di prendere decisioni
che influiscono sul futuro del pianeta!
Vediamo cosa succede
nel campo dell'agroalimentare.
Una piccola digressione:
una parrucchiera, una volta,
per convincermi a fare una tintura
mi disse: “È senza chimica!”
Ora, a parte che se fosse stata
davvero senza chimica
quella tintura non avrebbe funzionato.
Ma non sarebbe proprio esistita
perché la chimica è letteralmente ovunque!
La chimica è vita, la vita è chimica.
Ma noi veniamo bombardati da anni
da una bizzarra equivalenza:
“naturale = buono”,
la natura è bene, l'artificiale è male.
Ma forse è il caso di ricordare
che la natura può anche uccidere,
per esempio nel caso della segale cornuta
che causa un’intossicazione
mortale, l'ergotismo.
O che le scoperte dell'uomo
possono salvare la vita.
Pensiamo ai diabetici:
l'insulina che utilizzano
è da anni prodotta
da microrganismi geneticamente modificati
per produrre insulina umana.
Un tempo si usava quella dei maiali,
ma dava effetti collaterali
abbastanza pesanti.
La natura,
con la "n" rigorosamente minuscola,
non è né madre né matrigna.
Semplicemente, si fa i fatti suoi.
E i fatti suoi sono che ogni specie
lotta per sopravvivere.
Ecco perché naturale può anche uccidere,
[ed] ecco perché artificiale,
nel senso di manipolato dall'uomo,
può salvare la vita.
Niente di ciò che coltiviamo è naturale,
ma non lo è da quando
l'uomo è diventato agricoltore,
ha cominciato a cambiare
le piante, a selezionarle,
a migliorarle per i propri scopi.
Confondere natura e agricoltura
è una scorciatoia che apparentemente
semplifica i nostri processi decisionali,
ma in realtà è una strada
chiusa, una trappola.
La natura è una risorsa preziosa,
noi dobbiamo tutelarla,
ne va della nostra sopravvivenza.
Ma questo non è compito dell'agricoltura.
L'agricoltura non è naturale,
è un processo artificiale.
Confondere natura e agricoltura
ci porta al paradosso per eccellenza,
che è quello di rifiutare l'innovazione
anche quando riduce l'impatto ambientale.
L’esempio più eclatante
è quello del mais Bt.
Si tratta di un mais
geneticamente modificato
per proteggersi da solo
dagli attacchi di un insetto, la piralide.
Ma in Italia non è permesso coltivarlo.
Quindi noi, per proteggere il nostro mais,
per evitare che venga
attaccato dalla piralide,
e che diventi una schifezza invendibile,
tossico per le persone e per gli animali
che dovessero nutrirsene,
siamo costretti a trattare a tappeto
i nostri campi di mais con insetticida.
Proviamo a fare un’altra riflessione:
davanti a una malattia
noi chiediamo alla medicina
l'ultimo ritrovato,
oppure alla tecnologia informatica
chiediamo sempre maggior rapidità.
E tutto questo lo pretendiamo,
ma contemporaneamente ci disorienta.
Il tempo del progresso è rapido,
a volte troppo perché la società
si adegui senza disagio,
e allora cerchiamo un punto di riferimento
che ci rassicuri, ci dia certezze.
Il cibo è l’ancora perfetta:
quando si tratta del cibo,
di mettere in bocca i frutti del campo,
qualcosa scatta dentro di noi,
vogliamo a tutti i costi
essere rassicurati che sia tradizionale,
che sia come una volta,
che sia il cibo della nonna.
Illudendoci di preservare un passato
che, credetemi, ci viene dipinto
come molto più roseo
di quanto in realtà non fosse,
noi impediamo all'agricoltura di innovare
e in definitiva condanniamo
a morte le nostre tradizioni.
Eppure, se andassimo a vedere
come furono accolti alla loro introduzione
alcuni degli alimenti
che oggi consideriamo tipici
della nostra gastronomia,
resteremmo stupiti.
La melanzana, per esempio.
Fu introdotta in Italia
nel Medioevo dagli arabi.
Secondo alcune fonti, il suo nome
deriva da “mela insana”.
Oppure le patate,
i pomodori, come saprete,
sono originari del Sudamerica:
per molto tempo in Europa
furono considerati velenosi.
Ma un esempio molto interessante
è quello della pastorizzazione del latte:
nella metà dell'Ottocento,
nelle città americane,
la mortalità infantile
aveva raggiunto il 50%,
molto anche a causa dell'abitudine
di consumare latte crudo.
Quando fu introdotto l'obbligo
alla pastorizzazione del latte,
la gente scese in strada,
ci furono violente sommosse,
non ne volevano sapere di questa novità!
Pensavano fosse un imbroglio
escogitato dall'industria
per riuscire a smerciare
un prodotto avariato.
Guardate che i meccanismi mentali
sono sempre gli stessi ancora oggi.
Eppure la mortalità infantile
crollò di due terzi.
Proviamo allora a smontare
un piatto tipico della nostra tradizione:
la pasta al pomodoro.
Il grano per fare la pasta
deriva dalla fusione totale
dei genomi di due
diverse piante selvatiche
avvenuta in natura,
in modo del tutto casuale,
migliaia di anni fa.
Altro che OGM, dove si sposta un gene:
qui i geni si sono spostati tutti
e senza l'intervento dell'uomo.
Forse potremmo dire
che il grano è un OGM naturale.
E il pomodoro per fare il sugo,
lo abbiamo visto, viene dal Sud America.
E se vogliamo aggiungere
un po’ di basilico, molto bene,
ma che si sappia: è originario dell'India.
Allora la conclusione di questa deliziosa
pastasciutta al pomodoro e basilico
è che forse noi italiani
siamo davvero bravi a innovare,
a prendere i frutti del mondo
e a metterli insieme.
Riusciamo a innovare le nostre tradizioni?
Perché siamo giunti al punto
che, se vogliamo salvarle,
dobbiamo davvero applicare loro
una bella dose di sana innovazione.
Ma cosa significa innovazione
in agricoltura? Perché ci serve?
Ci serve per cambiare, perché
i nostri processi produttivi, nel tempo,
diventano obsoleti, costosi,
inadeguati alle sfide del pianeta.
Dobbiamo innovare perché
i patogeni nel tempo cambiano
e a noi servono nuovi metodi
per difendere le nostre colture
senza aumentare
la pressione sull'ambiente.
Dobbiamo innovare
perché il clima sta cambiando,
e bisogna adattare le piante
all'ambiente, non viceversa.
Ci servono piante
che tollerino la salinità,
piante che tollerino la carenza
idrica in caso di siccità.
O, viceversa, piante che tollerino
la sommersione in caso di alluvioni.
Il clima e l'ambiente stanno cambiando
e noi non possiamo
farci cogliere impreparati,
anche perché abbiamo
tutte le competenze per farlo.
Dobbiamo innovare perché i mercati,
la società stessa nel tempo cambiano
e a noi serve elasticità
per adeguarci alle loro esigenze.
Guardiamo al Made in Italy.
Il Made in Italy è un grande successo,
è richiestissimo in tutto il mondo.
Le esportazioni dell'industria alimentare
continuano a crescere.
Fa piacere, ma... avete notato?
Ho detto industria alimentare,
non agroalimentare.
Perché noi soddisfiamo solo metà
del nostro fabbisogno
di cereali alimentari e zootecnici.
E solo un terzo del nostro
fabbisogno di proteine vegetali.
Il resto lo importiamo.
Ciò significa che i prodotti necessari
a produrre i mangimi
che diamo agli animali
che ci forniranno il Made in Italy -
prosciutti, formaggi, salumi eccetera,
sono in buona parte importati,
e spesso sono geneticamente modificati.
Sono del tutto sicuri, sia ben chiaro,
ma sia ben chiaro anche
l'assurdo paradosso
in cui ci siamo ficcati,
cioè noi non consentiamo
ai nostri agricoltori di coltivare
ciò che poi importiamo in massa
per produrre il made in Italy.
Ma è un suicidio economico!
Un nonsenso scientifico,
è un pasticcio giuridico.
È un imbroglio!
Allora, se vogliamo salvare
la reputazione del made in Italy,
dell'agroalimentare italiano,
abbiamo bisogno di un'agricoltura
efficiente, performante, innovativa.
Ecco perché non c'è alcuna contraddizione
fra prodotto tradizionale e innovazione.
Innovazione, progresso, sono la chiave
verso un'agricoltura sostenibile.
E questo obiettivo
si raggiunge più in fretta
se agricoltori e ricercatori
lavorano insieme,
ognuno con le proprie competenze.
Lasciamo i ricercatori lIberi
di fare il loro mestiere.
Lasciamo le aziende libere
di scegliere gli strumenti
necessari a stare sul mercato.
Un'azienda economicamente vitale
è un'azienda in grado di aprire
le proprie porte alla società
e di mostrare con orgoglio come lavora.
La tutela dell'ambiente
è una priorità anche per noi agricoltori:
noi in quell'ambiente ci lavoriamo,
spesso ci viviamo.
Allora forse dovremmo riflettere sul fatto
che quello che noi oggi
chiamiamo tradizione,
i nostri nonni chiamavano innovazione.
Perché per noi agricoltori,
è tradizione innovare!
Grazie.
(Applausi)